[Music]
hey how is everything going in here yeah
you know just getting some last-minute
things done before we take her I'm gonna
take her to all of her favorite places
and then um I'm gonna spread her ashes I
am here to celebrate her life by
fulfilling her last dying wish of
finishing this bar cart and watching her
favorite show the husband did it
yes okay that is lovely she was so lucky
to have two great granddaughters no no
no no no we were the lucky one I was her
granddaughter but she was my Nana
he was Arden you're not related she
actually loved me as my Nana my my blood
she told me that before she she did not
say that all right
[Music]
all right you know what I'm gonna get
going cuz there's not a lot of time
before sundown I want you to take my
phone I want it to be just me and Ana
today so also thank you for helping wait
here
shots for Nana Oh
- our Nana say my Nana our Nana Kelsey
to our 99 there for the love of God
my Nana okay
I use it a solid how would it be but
sitting here I just feel my breath
through my nose okay gran are you ready
to have the best day ever
besides you know love back we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
brother my husband did it
hello hey miss Peterman no they deserve
a best friend but we're basically you
know yes this is her who's this this is
Paul from live to die another day
mortuary how are you doing
hang in there Paul now this is hang in
there real quick there has been a little
bit of a mix-up with the urns this
morning
what yesyes there was what we call here
a switcher whoops we kind of gave you
the wrong urn Hey
so you didn't give us Nana yes yes you
did her yes you did it did it didn't yes
you didn't give us Nana we didn't not
switcher whoops to put it plainly you
need to say that slower down for me we
didn't give you the correct urn what you
have there is the wrong person what did
who do we have
oh my god don't know where they are
okay when you're lost it's best to stay
in one place okay spread ashes aren't
rooftop that's lucky in ten minutes I
got ashes see ya
[Music]
good well thanks focal dropping she's
walking out she's gonna get there in
time
[Music]
all right Graham it's time
what the hell I'm eating yogurt Graham I
just died
[ __ ] you you wish no I don't
[Music]
[Music]
is there anything else left to do no
you're right let's just do it
hey Kelsey yeah
[Music]
[Music]
how did he give them on the runner what
do you tell who don't [ __ ] do I have
that Amanda oh my god isn't it was
Haun's right look under the [ __ ] whip
just watched it go honey
yeah did I just spend all beautiful
there's a friend Ozzy
[Music]
it's a little bit like a castle if you
ask me what do you think it looks like
[Music]
hi grandma
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]